welcome to a new year of coffee on a
Tuesday and blood date is gonna show
this is gonna be late I'm sorry 45 so I
have a reason why the vlog is late this
week and that reason is of course
Downton Abbey I thought I would just see
what the fuss was about this thing so
you know I just put on one episode that
was gonna be it but then I didn't have
to marry him you know and then months
ago before I left Peter said we need a
rat poison and I bought and then what am
i shooting a swivel chair so I lost
track of time
okay the crawl is watching the show
episode by episode though dangerous to
my day-to-day responsibilities gave me a
sense of the show's broader narrative
for me the show seems to follow this
pattern desire desire desire giving in
to that desire then dealing with the
consequences negative or positive from
giving in to that desire and then
starting the process all over again with
a new set of initial condition is this
what our lives are really like after all
we are creatures of desire each day were
pushed and pulled by once by our desire
for things for status for people for
pleasure small pleasures feelings of
pleasure are the easiest to obtain it's
why we drink coffee or alcohol it's why
we do drugs or lose ourselves in
Upstairs Downstairs British drama our
desires for a more sustained pleasure
for status or knowledge take time to
achieve we stave off the fulfillment of
more immediate pleasures if we can to
work for something great these greater
desires we often seek to justify to
other people we tell them about our plan
yet in that process which may take
months or years we're learning and
growing all the time and our desires
often change sometimes we realize that
we don't want what we originally set out
to achieve we want something new but all
the time and energy we've put into our
now-defunct desires and all the people
we've told about them and the desire
itself repeated so many times that its
entangled in our personalities makes any
change very hard here we are at the
first step of the down
Nabby formula subversive desire begins
to grow within our already organized
life organized by ourselves by others by
our social class until the pressure
becomes too great and we give in and
open the door to both our desire and the
consequences that come from action
sometimes actually almost all the time
in fact giving in to new desires is a
gamble we're gambling what we have for
what we want and we may come out a loser
on both counts Downton Abbey shows us
that the risk for those with means is
not nearly as great as it is for those
without though neither can seem to
resist giving in at least once in a
while both the upper and lower classes
in our case the great middle-class must
face the truly absurd truth that our
short lives are constrained by arbitrary
rules rules we ourselves made up and
agree to many of our best desires go
unfulfilled the desires made to expand
us to open us the desire to live
unimpeded in a world of impetus ah well
that's sad to think about maybe I can
cheer myself up with the first episode
of Breaking Bad
[Music]